ومعظمنا يعرف جيدا سواء الترفيهيه للسفر
لكن الجديد ان للسفر فوائد الصحيه ايضا
دراسته امريكيه حديثه اجراها الباحثون في
جامعه تكساس اظهرت ان اولئك الذين يسافرون
يبلغون عن نتائج صحيات اكثر على كل حال
الاشخاص الذين لا يسافرون خارج منطقتهم
يبلغون عن صحه اقل فقد تبين بحسب الدراسه
ان الاشخاص الذين لديهم فرص سفر محدوده
يعانون من ضعف الصحه ووفقا لدراسه يمكن ان
يؤدي اجراء تفاعلات اجتماعيه خلال السفر
الى تحسين الحاله المزاجيه والمساعده على
الشعور بالسعاده مما يقلل من خطر الاصابه
بالخلف الامر لا يقتصر على السفر الترفيهي
الهجره ايضا لها منافع صحيه فلذين يسافرون
الى خارج منطقههم المحليه يتمكنون من
الوصول لا خيارات رعايه صحيه اكثر وربما
افضل
[موسيقى]